e não é um acaso um azar arma mera
casualidade
e a pandemia do coronavírus é um reflexo
da forma com que a gente se relaciona
com a natureza
e vamos vale a pena dizer a gente se
relaciona mal com ela confirmamos bois
vacas porcos patos galinhas em ambientes
pequenos ou grandes e condições
precárias somente para matá-los e
devorados
é mas não queremos ver um galpão
iluminado com fortes luzes de halogéneo
onde milhares de galinhas se apertam
confinados lutando por um minúsculo
espaço sem penas cobertas de piolhos de
feridas pisoteando outras galinhas já
mortas em decomposição e cacarejando em
continuo sofrimento o que a gente quer
mesmo é ir no supermercado e comprar um
frango uma bandeja asséptica
e a gente arranca barbatanas de tubarão
chifres de renoceronte presas de
elefantes escamas de pangolins mas a
gente não quer ver esses animais
engaiolados nos mercados da china a
gente não quer saber que eles são
abandonados a morte sangrando
e a gente joga toneladas de lixo no mar
mas queremos praias limpas o oceano sem
golfinhos entalados no plástico 100
garrafas boiando invadimos e destruímos
florestas savanas campos mares ignoramos
o que essas paisagens podem nos trazer
desprezamos os serviços que a natureza
nos oferece que fazem com que esse
planeta seja convidativo para nossa
espécie mas não queremos enfrentar as
consequências de socorro
é mas é justamente dessas relações
e com as quais compactuamos todos os
dias temperadas com a cobiça humana
organizadas no sistema
político-econômico
e é dessas relações inácio boa parte das
pandemias que aterrorizaram a humanidade
inclusive essa que nos prende em casa
hoje
e claro ouvi muitas outras pandemias
essa não é a primeira pandemia que a
humanidade enfrenta
em outras pandemias mataram milhões de
pessoas na antiguidade na idade média e
segue matando o século passado em 1918 a
gripe espanhola matou algo em torno de
30 50 milhões de pessoas depois ao longo
do século 20 outras epidemias deixaram
um rastro de milhares mortos
e já no século 21 tivemos a epidemia das
ar e sucessivos surtos de bola e também
de outras doenças virais como a zika
dengue
e vale lembrar e todos os vírus que
circulam na natureza
e eles dependem de um outro organismo
para se reproduzir
e os vírus usam o maquinário da célula
de um outro ser vivo daí ele se
multiplicam e aí se espalham os seus
também se transformam rapidamente assim
eles conseguem se instalar em
hospedeiros hoje as suas versões
anteriores não conseguiam o problema é
que essa nossa forma de lidar com a
natureza ajuda esse processo e
destruímos florestas savanas outros
ecossistemas se modificamos o clima do
planeta forçamos os animais a se
deslocarem e assim eles encontram outros
animais com os quais eles jamais teriam
contato antes isso facilita o trânsito
do vírus
e além disso
e as nossas relações com a natureza se
modificaram muito e nos últimos cem anos
se consolidaram como uma saga depredação
só ficamos as nossas formas de matar os
animais que usamos na alimentação humana
nós multiplicamos confinamos ea batemos
mais
e nós ampliamos as os nossos impactos
sobre os ambientes naturais desmatamos
mais florestas convertemos mais savanas
em áreas de agricultura e pecuária o
windows solos mares águas estamos
mudando o clima do planeta
as espécies que habitavam das
profundezas da floresta no meio da
savana agora são obrigadas a viver em
áreas próximas às cidades o mesmo em
áreas urbanas e assim convivem com
animais domésticos ou aqueles destinados
ao abate a nossa espécie além disso hoje
ocupa virtualmente todos os cantos desse
planeta e faz isso com grandes
populações de milhões de indivíduos
concentrados em pequenos espaços
e isso tudo articulado o sistema
econômico tão predatório e além de
causar grande dano aos ambientes
naturais ele impede que os produtos da
agricultura e da pecuária chegue a todos
que precisam de comida assim milhões de
pessoas tem que usar outras estratégias
para garantir sua subsistência e muitas
dessas estratégias se relacionam como a
destruição dos ambientes naturais e
também com tráfico o abate de animais
silvestres
e o tráfego de empresas de elefante
chifres de rinocerontes aves como araras
e papagaios peixes ornamentais é um
exemplo disso mas outras outros também
criam animais silvestres para alimentar
sim gente faminta mas também para
alimentar um mercado de itens exclusivos
em restaurantes caros clientes ricos
nesse cenário
é uma nova pandemia pode estar a nossa
espreita a qualquer momento a
organização mundial da saúde já disse
que o mundo onde surtos de doenças
mortais são mais frequentes é o novo
normal isso pode começar aqui mesmo no
brasil estima-se que há mais de 3.000
tipos de coronavírus os morcegos
brasileiros além disso animais como bois
porcos cabras carneiros vacas são
repositórios de inúmeros outros tipos de
vírus uma mistura dessas coisas você
errado ou na amazônia tendo como pano de
fundo uma paisagem degradada pode ser o
cenário perfeito para emergência de uma
nova pandemia global
e outras doenças tem também a destruição
ambiental como estopim
e o surto de ebola em relação com a
conversão de áreas naturais de floresta
em áreas de monocultura
oi e o surto de ebola seguem
sucessivamente assolando todo o
continente africano na amazônia
epidemias de malária leishmaniose estão
fortemente relacionadas com a degradação
ambiental hoje é possível estabelecer
uma relação entre o número de hectares
de floresta desmatada e o aumento de
casos de malária e leishmaniose
sim mas mas parece que ninguém se comove
nem se move ou nada disso
e a destruição da amazônia se acelera
cada minuto e quantos estamos aqui nessa
crise de saúde
e as atividades predatórias só aumentam
por lá numa combinação explosiva entre a
contaminação dos povos da floresta pelo
novo coronavírus com o aumento
escandaloso da grilagem do desmatamento
e da criação de condições para a
emergência de novas doenças
e quando desistimos das florestas
uma das savanas dos mares desistirmos de
nós mesmos quando falhamos em nos
perceber como parte da natureza quando
colocamos nossas fichas numa tecnologia
que é muitas vezes inspirada na natureza
essa mesmo que não hesitamos em destruir
quando achamos que é normal que poucos
seres humanos devoram em todo o planeta
enquanto outros precisam ter sua alma
devorada todos os dias para garantir sua
subsistência descobrimos que há muito
pouco para ser chamado ainda de
humanidade
nós sabemos disso e sabemos disso há
muito tempo
é a pergunta que nos atormenta agora é o
que de fato vamos aprender nessa com
anemia as nossas relações com a natureza
vão mudar de fato
e a muita gente que diz que o mundo
jamais será o mesmo depois dessa
academia para o bem e para o mal
é mas não basta entender que estamos
vivendo um momento extraordinário uma
janela de oportunidade como se diz
e é preciso explicar seriamente esse
futuro pois pandêmico
e é preciso criar desenhar novos
caminhos e
em concretos e tangíveis hoje as pessoas
consigam se enxergar
é mas talvez esse seja exatamente o
maior empecilho para um novo mundo
estamos estão convencidos e a somente um
jeito certo de viver e não conseguimos
sequer imaginar outras formas de estar
no mundo esse pretenso jeito certo de
viver
quem colonizou de tal maneira o nosso
imaginário que se quer vislumbramos
outros modos possíveis e tradução disso
é que enquanto nos debatemos com a ideia
de que o presente é uma máquina de fazer
futuro outro futuro já começa a ser
desenhado com menos floresta - natureza
mais doenças mais desigualdade e menos
oportunidades quem sabe quem expirações
as soberanas da floresta o dia trazer
para a humanidade quem sabe que mundos
poderiam emergir depois dessa academia e
não estivéssemos tão irremediavelmente
imersos nesse presente sem horizontes
e o mundo só vai se transformar com
muito esforço e talvez mesmo esse
momento tão extraordinário essa pandemia
não sei jogar tiro suficiente
e para essa mudança
e os nosso comportamento carrega uma uma
inércia gigantesca e talvez mudanças
rápidas sejam muito difíceis
e o presente é de fato uma máquina de
fazer futuros mas o presente também é
reflexo do passado onde ele foi talhado
como futuro
e se não nos lançarmos a essa aventura
de buscar uma nova possibilidade de
mundo disputando o futuro poste
pandêmico até às suas últimas
consequências não haverá um novo gol
o presente delineará o futuro com mais
do mesmo e saberemos tem como espécie
perdemos arrasou linda é muito bom ainda
bem que ela canal parabéns obrigada
então é
e aí